foreign
[Music]
two one here we go
three two one here we go
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
questions
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
forever
foreign
[Music]
myself hello everyone this is your daily
dose of internet
I win
[Music]
I'm gonna have to do it
what's good Turtle Squad it's your boy
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
I'm gonna win this thing
he has to move his brown man whoa whoa
you could do that I can't move your
crown man like that
they have this chest rabbit that's just
terrible oh
ladies and gentlemen
welcome everybody to pogchamps five this
is the final day of the groove stage I'm
Anna crowning and today I'm joined by
Andrea botas how are you doing Andrea
hello Anna I'm very excited today is
gonna be the most professional
commentary you've ever seen because
they're letting adults run the show
finally I'm glad we finally get a chance
to do a commentary together
me too Andrea I honestly don't really
know how they let us do this together
but I'm very excited
it's gonna be a big day chat for many
reasons
it's gonna be super exciting we're gonna
check out all the standings because like
I said this is the final day of the
group stage and a drought we got some
really important matches coming up today
but let's check out the groups so group
a everybody is decided over there Group
B everybody's decided as well in group C
we can see everyone is decided too it's
gonna be real to see where we're gonna
be seeing our eighth person that's going
to the championship bracket and that is
going to be between cutie Cinderella and
papa plot cutie Cinderella needs to win
today Andrea are you excited to see this
eighth person going to the going to the
championship racket yeah you know after
yesterday I don't know if excited would
be the correct term more like more like
concerned however however after you know
not that first stalemate not the second
but the third game we got the Checkmate
I hope that overnight cutie Cinderella
has become a master at checkmating and
I'm really excited to see what she
brings on today
I'm sure she's become a grand master
overnight Andrea but you know why this
is also so exciting it's because we're
gonna be getting some live finals for
the very first time in park Champs five
and those live finals are gonna be the
18th of August in La the city you live
in Andrea how does that feel does that
mean you're gonna finally come visit me
again Anna
my routines you were roasting everything
that I was doing you know on draft but I
would very gladly come and visit you for
something as special as the live finals
that would be absolutely amazing that
was your routine in Sweden not in
America but I would gladly host you me
and Hikaru welcome you into our Humble
Home you can't see his face but um you
should totally come visit for La finals
all right well we will see if I make a
little surprise visit anyways let's go
ahead and focus on today's matches
because we got two very special matches
happening today the first one being
between cutie Cinderella and papa plot
and this is gonna be absolutely amazing
I mean this is a match that's really
going to decide who the eighth person to
go to the championship bracket is the
loser of this match uh might go to the
consolation bracket but we'll go ahead
and talk about that and then after that
Andrea xqc versus tyler1 I mean there's
been beef going on here what's going on
dude I don't even know I I look chat I'm
not a gamer I can't tell if it's a joke
if it's real but I am terrified tyler1
said that he would snap xqc like a
pencil and then xuc said that Tyler is
so bad at chess he shouldn't be allowed
to play in the tournament so today
they're gonna settle it once for all and
fight each other in the ultimate
Gladiator Battle of chess
it's going to be terrifying I don't even
know if I'm ready for it Andrea but I'm
so excited it's gonna be absolutely
amazing so you've been doing a daily
watch party of pogchamps I'm assuming
you're you're pretty familiar with you
know tyler1 and all our competitors here
in the talk that they've been bringing
to the tournament
I've been watching all interviews I've
been seeing all the clips I've been very
into this podcast Andrea and you know
I've been rooting for it for a virtual
he's being my student this year
unfortunately virtually it's not making
it to the championship bracket and he's
not playing today but it's been really
fun to follow all of this but let's go
ahead and check out the first player of
today's match cue to Cinderella I mean
Andre you know cute it very well I mean
she is an OG of pogtails but she's also
created a lot of events such as the
stream rewards which was last time I
visited you yeah yep I will I know her
very well and I had many nightmares
after the games yesterday so it's very
hard to forget but not to belittle how
amazing of a streamer cutie is she hosts
some of the biggest events on Twitch she
is the queen of twitch like Anna said
the streamer Awards we have seen Kitty
be in the face of some of the most
entertaining events and I would like to
see her be the face of one of the
championship Defenders as well
me too I'm very excited to see it you
know she's got over 1500 games she's
played a lot of Chess and I'm wondering
if she is right now already maybe
playing a little bit of Chess to get
ready for the game yeah I mean last time
when we tuned in on our chess prep she
was shopping for Taylor Swift tickets
but it's big priorities and I understand
and honestly maybe if we put them on the
line it would motivate her but cutie is
a veteran she has played chess starting
in 2020 when chess is blown up and um
speaking of yesterday's games the thing
I really want to see from cutie today is
she does have great instincts for the
board and Danny was giving us a really
good psychoanalysis where she kind of
crumbles on the pressure and gets in her
own head and I want her to show up with
the confidence that she deserves today
and and take us to the Checkmate maybe
maybe a little faster
yeah I I totally agree I want to see
that too but she's facing a strong
opponent today she is facing Papa Platt
who's one of the biggest dreamers from
Germany and I'm very excited to see you
know people all over the world
participating in POG Champs 5 and I mean
he's representing Germany in this in
this tournament now Papa plot he is uh
also an OG of podcast he participated in
POG Champs one so there's a second
appearance and he has over 900 games
played on chess.com so not as many as
cutie but he's played a lot of Chess as
well what do you think is going to
happen in this match Andrea I'm not
gonna lie yesterday was my first time
watching him play and you know he missed
a couple botas gambits here and there
but he was pretty strong and cutie is
really gonna have to put up a fight she
has what it takes but she's gonna you
know not only get a winning position but
bring the Checkmate home
um he's very good at bringing an attack
but similar to a lot of our POG Champs
players one blender and it's over if
your opponent sees it exactly
yes exactly I don't know what is going
on about I was asking chat yesterday to
uh help us translate because you know
Anna you speak many languages yourself
but I don't think either of us speak
German
now I speak Swedish which is a tiny
little bit close to German but I don't
know any German at all so he can say
anything and we are not gonna understand
him chat will have to tell us what he
thinks that we actually understand but
I'm very excited I hope he makes it to
the interview as well so that we can you
know all unite yeah that'll be a very
interesting interview but honestly
that's kind of how they've all been
going
I'm excited we also need to check the
standings of Group D because like I said
this match really matters I mean we can
see here the cutest Cinderella she's on
two points right now Papa plot is on
five but if cutie Cinderella would win
before the tie breaks and she would get
three points which means that she would
get the same points as Papa plot and
because she has beaten him in the match
um she would be the one going to the
championship bracket actually so that
would mean that Papa Platt would go to
the consolation bracket so she needs to
win before the tie break if Papa plot
takes it to the tie break he's in the
championship bracket so this is going to
get very exciting
yeah there's a lot of pressure on the
line for Cutie today not only does she
have to not stalemate a single game but
she has to win all of them yesterday we
went into tie breaks against fusely and
she cannot take that risk today if she
wants to get into the championship
bracket no she cannot she cannot sell me
she I really hope that she stops taking
pawns and stops taking pieces she needs
to be a little bit just greedy just
leaves one punch just one that's what I
was like cutie they're just small Paws
they're not gonna do anything you really
don't have to worry about them we can't
just leave the pawns on the board
exactly that is exactly it so the games
I'm sure are gonna start very soon but
I'm very very excited to see this Andrea
do you have like do you have anyone
you're rooting for I mean I know her
commentators maybe we shouldn't be
biased but it's kind of fun so one thing
I I did kind of want to bring up well
luckily it's not this match that we're
commentating but um you were saying how
you've been doing very serious coaching
with virtual I have been coaching two
contenders in the championship racket
both sapnap and gasly and you know my
student beat your student Anna well
thanks for pointing that out Andrea but
you know here's the thing I've been
going all in with one person but okay
we're gonna go ahead and check out this
game we have more time to beef about uh
about our students we got cue to
Cinderella who's right now getting ready
for the game to start it's going to
start at any point I think she's having
the white pieces in the first round
um it looks like it right I think she's
gonna have the white pieces and this is
gonna start in any second Andrea I'm
nervous
I between the two streams going on
um I I don't understand what Papa plate
is looking at maybe we could preview
between the two but this is some very
inter very interesting preparation okay
he was just searching up chess memes oh
I think the game has wait he's playing
yes okay it starts off with a Ludwig's
face and I wasn't sure if this is the
right game if he was accidentally
playing like a fan account but I think
this is Cutie's chest.com account yep no
I mean she's been having the Ludwig
profile picture every single game and it
was actually kind of funny because when
she celebrated yesterday kind of
reminded me of Ludwig's still made a few
years ago especially because of the fact
that she had her his profile picture so
I think we're gonna get the game right
over here very soon but we can see that
Bishop D3 okay Andrea they're going are
they gonna go for a symmetrical again
kind of like firstly cutie uh yesterday
oh boy and not only foosli cutie but
Papa plate did do the same copycat
strategy seems like this isn't a
complete okay now you really can't copy
but that was his go-to but now it's time
for him to think outside of the box
exactly now he really needs to think and
he's doing it actually so now we can see
that it's becoming a bit of a different
position but I think that this is
looking very solid I mean this is the
sort of position where you can't really
go wrong in the opening too early on I
feel like and that's the most important
thing in POG Champs to not just you know
get into some big trap in the beginning
like I know you prepared for gasoline
one of the previous matches you proved
some really big traps well we tried but
it didn't work let's let's see what
cutie is thinking as well
so maybe well I was gonna say we should
turn cutie up but yeah do you hear her I
think she's just quiet this morning
she's taking it seriously I'll say that
it's really important platypus
don't like cutie woke up like 10 minutes
ago like but you know what I did
commentary in my pj pens yesterday too
it's pretty sick Chad is saying cutie is
sick oh she feels better that's a really
unfortunate morning to wake up oh yeah
that that would really that would really
not be good
um but I hope she feels better I mean
she looks very focused I think that she
looks confident and focused and I mean
it would be amazing if you know she won
and got to the championship bracket you
know wearing her pajamas that would be
amazing I'd love to see that
that's what's weird I'm not super
congested my throat doesn't hurt I just
have like an awful I have a headache and
I'm so nauseous
oh no
thank you guys for the subs well
now Papa plate Shirley can't beat a sick
woman like that would just be cruel
it's just not fair come on no no not
fair at all okay Andra we finally got
the position on our board so the last
move we saw was C5 I feel like this is
being like some really good move so far
like what's going on this actually looks
like a very solid game like I would I
would think that this could be a game
between like two two thousand people
this could be our game
yep what I wanted to say about cutie is
her openings are very solid she
typically goes for like a stone wall
setup but um she's very good at getting
a strong position out of the opening and
then maintaining her Advantage
um we're gonna see if that happens this
game yeah I hope that she's able to
maintain her advantage throughout the
whole game and also at the last part of
the game so that she can really you know
pull through the whole way but so far it
looks very solid she has an amazing
night right in the center of the board
um puppet plot has this Knight on on B4
but the Knight is not really doing much
right now I don't think it's that scary
okay so now cute is trying to kick it
away and is there something we're
missing Andre is there any reason why
this would be uh bad for white here I
was just gonna say I mean black is happy
to take this bishop the light squared
Bishop for white is a very strong piece
because White's dark squared Bishop's
not doing much and once that comes off
the board black and E then activate
their light squared Bishop even
eventually come into the A6 diagonal
attacking the queen going for the pin
and he takes the bishop I think he's a
very good trade for Papa plot the one
lesson I've seen in pogchamps is people
have really studied their principles and
this goes same for virtual's game he was
such a disciplined player but the one
principle they have not been following
is to keep the bishop here yeah yeah I
appreciate you saying some you know
positive comments about virtually I
heard your commentary was very biased
the other day and I was like I wanna
jump in here and give a little bit of
bias commentary look you're taking over
commentary tomorrow I and I no no I was
100 applauding him and praising him for
his amazing chess I've been saying from
the beginning that he's kind of one of
the strongest contenders and I think
he's gonna completely crush his group so
no disrespect to your student but um you
know I gotta root for my student too I
said to your students because you've
been coaching several people you know I
went all in with one person Andrea I
believed in one person and I went you
know ride or die with them in the chest
that's that's and I know it's it's
becoming a problem because they're both
in championships and sapnap sent me some
very angry messages yesterday after the
broadcast I didn't know he was listening
oh boy okay this is this is not obvious
to see I know we have these red question
marks on the board there is a pawn move
winning a piece but it's not that clear
it's uh but if he doesn't it's gonna be
I mean it's gonna be a piece it's gonna
be a piece the pawn will be both looking
at the queen and at the bishop at the
same time so Papa Platt will be winning
a piece let's go ahead and see if Papa
plaid actually sees this
he luckily makes a lot of arrows so even
if we can't understand we'll see what
he's thinking
that is the good attack and he's
prepping
come on not a bad plan
yeah for sure he's right now just
looking at Queen moves and looks like
he's kind of scared of Cutie's Knight
and he ends up
the piece he ends up going Queen C8
which is not I think a terrible move but
he did have a good chance there of
winning a piece
yeah I think for beginners I mean I
don't know much they've been doing their
puzzle Rush that's definitely one thing
that helps but these type of pattern
recognition like this discovery attacks
are not as obvious but I like that he is
setting something up right now
no for sure for sure but that's kind of
what happens okay actually he has I
think he can do the same move again oh
but he prepared a difference a different
idea this is your idea Andreas
which I I like this plan even if he
missed the free piece okay he's oh
gonna go for it
white can't push their pawn and block
which I saw he was making arrows on that
earlier but this is very good pressure
on the queen and now you're going to be
pinning that pawn definitely a good
Target to attack no I think that the
more threats that you do at this level
the absolute better it is I keep on
telling people to just like keep on
threatening things uh because it's
there's a lot of pressure when your
opponent is threatening stuff but
fortunately cutie did see the threat and
she won C4 which was the boss move
blocking right now the whole light
Square diagonal but not only that now
black cannot go for this idea of C4 and
and winning the bishop so she's actually
stopping two things at one so this move
was very important for her to do
he definitely missed his chance with
that tactic but the one idea I like
about this capture is now the B7
diagonal is also open which a lot of
beginners can get tricky and aim for
that G2 Square maybe bring in the queen
so I see a future sniper on there I see
it too and I see that you're seeing a
lot of things for Papa plot which is
really good and dry you keep on seeing
things for Papa plot I keep on seeing
things for cutie I'm just pointing out
what's good in the position but on on
Cutie's end that's true she has those
strong knights in the center I think I
really love my Bishops the one thing
that I've taken from my Grandmaster
lessons with hammers number one I'll
never be good enough but number two
never forget the Bishops are very
important and he's kind of ingrained it
in my brains so yeah that's that's
probably why nah the Bishops are really
strong here but speaking of hammer
Andrea how does it feel that hammer
actually also decided to coach uh a
virtual he kind of you know he kind of
decided to coach someone else does that
hurt yeah I I it doesn't hurt you know I
like that the Norwegians are uniting I
mean virtual went to the same high
school as Magnus Carlson like he is
breathing that Norwegian air I think
it's a reason he's very strong and and
I'm okay with that because we took him
down regardless
okay that's good well uh I was hoping
you'd be a little bit more sad about it
but that's that's a very uh mature
approach not the most loyal chess coach
but I'm maybe not the most loyal student
so it goes both ways all right so we're
saying that the evil virus right now
really swinging and the reason for it is
because like you said the Bishops are
very strong in this position
cutie setting up some trash tricky dude
white is completely is this gonna be the
game or cutie clean sweeps oh my God
made it too
she did it she's gonna Roar immediately
this is insane what Yuri is the machine
for this this was okay let's tune into
cutie yeah let's see who knows what
she's doing wow what a what a lethal
mate
she has to see it now
I'll clean a jade oh
beautiful
all right Maiden one come on cutie hold
on oh okay oh yes yes is this real Anna
I can't tell I don't know am I dreaming
wow she did it let's go okay cutie
taking the win
I think I might have played a close to
perfect stone wall there
that was kind of beautiful like that
after yesterday she redeemed herself and
not only redeemed but what quick win
like that was how many moves 12 moves
this is absolutely the same way how many
moves was it it was 20 moves 20 moves is
that not crazy Andrea that's pretty
impressive and it's not like you know
Papa plate is just xqc and pogchamps one
he is a strong opponent and this is
exactly what we wanted to see they need
to go head to head if cutie wants to
make it into the championship she has to
do this again
no yeah she needs just a draw now that's
everything she's gonna need for the next
game just to draw
um but if she's able to pull that off
then boom I mean she can even stalemate
now and she'll tell you she'll still be
winning oh I didn't realize she gets a
draw okay but don't tell her that don't
tell her that it's better that she
doesn't know but no seriously Amazing by
Cutie's part like I don't know how that
I was you know praising all these things
in the positions for black and she set
it up perfectly
let's see what Papa plot thought about
this game I mean how must he feel after
this okay
he seems upset
yeah no idea what do you say okay
it's good that he seems focused though
he seems very focused he's trying to see
what his mistakes were and he's
realizing now that he just forgot about
this queen takes H7 idea the one piece
of advice that I've given to everyone is
just insane cutie slow yourself down
when your opponent makes a move just in
your head what are they attacking why
did they go there constantly ask
yourself questions you kind of rushed
those last two moves and that's how the
game could be decided
yeah yeah he I guess he just didn't see
a danger in The Possession which is very
easy for it to happen
um so that's why I said that you just
gotta keep on doing threats and at some
point your opponents will miss it and
this is what cutie did she created a
threat on H7 very strong one and she was
able to pull it off which is amazing
we're very soon going to be seeing um
the next game as well cute is going to
have the black pieces Andrea now the
pressure is on Papa plot he needs to win
otherwise it's over if cutie takes
another dub this could be like the
fastest show in pogchamp's history that
is assuming that xqc rushes tyler1 or
the other way around but let's see if
cutie can clean this up
yep absolutely okay so
do you know if anyone's been coaching
Papa plot Andrea so I was yeah I was
also curious which what I liked about
his play yesterday is after his um get
matches he was tuning in to I believe
like a German chess master who was
analyzing his games and looking at it so
I don't know if he was coaching him but
I would assume that that guy was his
coach Tech you know with the streamer's
name Big Greek the Big Greek yes he
fired him oh what is that true why would
he fire him I hope he's an international
Master gotcha gotcha
um but it was very nice that he was yeah
I don't know but I like that not only
did Papa project kind of have some
really nice wins yesterday but he still
chose to analyze them and still was
trying to learn
yeah I I've seen that you know some
people really want to learn and it's
really amazing to see that they actually
want to improve at chess so we're gonna
see it what happens in this next game I
mean his Bishop is kind of hanging he
probably shouldn't okay no he's just
letting it go he's just letting go of
the exchanges okay A little bit of
pressure I like that is it just me or
was Papa Plate's hair a different color
yesterday I feel like he kind of just
turned into xqc today or maybe it was
always but chat this looks new or maybe
I didn't pay attention
do you not think it's the lighting maybe
no no I think he's channeling his inner
excuse me or maybe xqc is channeling his
inner Papa plate I don't know who did it
first but somebody did and we need to
get down to this
maybe you're right I I mean after seeing
you want to cut the wig
it was a cap I see oh it was a cop okay
all right let's go ahead and maybe check
out what he's thinking right now how is
he feeling
let's do it
he is always German xqc I wonder if he
doesn't like being called a German
excuse me
you can ask him later on I I feel like I
always ask the wrong questions
holy that ladies and gentlemen he
he is surprised he sees something
remind you Chad he just needs to win
this game and it's over for Cutie into
the championship it's not a draw it's
not a draw he needs to win so the
pressure is on him
I wonder if he knows it as well that you
know that he can't go to the tiebreaker
that he needs to win right here and
right now yeah the one thing I have been
learning exactly a lot of the POG
champers have no idea what they're
signing up for like daily dose the other
day was like why is the clock adding
time what is this this magic and then
and then he found out that if he lost it
didn't change anything and I was like I
don't think they're really reading any
rules or guidelines but maybe Papa plate
did
yeah I I really laughed when I saw that
that was really funny because I was
wondering like what do you even have
played if he knew that the game didn't
really matter yeah I don't know if he
knows what's on the line yes Anna go
ahead wait a second this move I mean
this is typically called the poison Pawn
the pawn on B2 so typically you don't
really want to take it too soon because
white can get all their pieces attacking
the queen and I'm wondering right now if
there are any tactics like
[Laughter]
he's gonna he's gonna do it Andrea of
course he just needs to move that dark
squared Bishop this is what I talk about
these are scenarios where he needs to
take his time slow down and look at all
he's doing it it works beautiful move
nice amazing snipers in the center
Cutie's Queen is in danger and I'm a
little worried for her this game
no I was gonna say but I think that a
lot of pieces are hanging here I mean
for instance Cuda could right now take
this bishop and if he took with the
Knight the bishop was hanging so a lot
of people are hanging but she decides to
not do anything she just moves up the
pawn but now there's Rook B1 threatening
the queen and the pawn and be salmon
Andrea that pawn is soon gonna be Papa
plots
ah yes I thought you were gonna say his
son or something I was expecting a
follow-up word but yeah I know cutie is
definitely in danger we should tune in
here what she's thinking but uh Papa
plot is coming back I'm assuming he's
seeing the attack on B7 but this is what
happens when all your pieces are active
like black has not castled she has five
pieces on the back rank this is not a
good look for move 14.
absolutely not let's see what cutie is
thinking right now
when Mr Cow you got him right now Mr
Tamil expert
this is him
did you say Mr calender are you talking
about the cow no the other cow
I have to preface again if you're a
pop-up plot fan and I just called him a
it's an endearing term
the one thing that I also learned about
cutie when I first discovered twitch is
don't take anything she says seriously
especially the words that she may call
you or your favorite streamer that's
just that's cutie oh no he's protected
there okay okay oh Andrea I'm scared now
Rook type B7 monster dude cuties King is
in a corner like he has one square The
Rook comes and then literally the King
house and then the oh God this is gonna
get this is really scary if he takes a
game yeah and the King cannot really
Castle anymore either I mean her King is
going to stay there
I'm kind of terrified
okay
like this is so dangerous how much is on
the line there's a threat right now
Chuck many one under if cutie doesn't
see it it's a chocolate one Rick the aid
or queen d8 checkmate
oh
hold it Anna uh all right 97
see some defense let's not end this game
we're not returning the favor today
no 97 was played okay yup very strong
move
let's do it I mean yep good no go on go
on I was gonna say I like I really want
to hear the players um thought process
for this because very critical so I'm
downstairs watch Papa's arrow and then
hear your analysis
okay evil bear has shut down
this is very scary papa pluck keeps on
wanting to go for checkmates in one but
now cutie can Queen side castle and then
she's gonna be completely safe and the
attack is gonna be on Papa plot instead
let's see what he's thinking right now
yep the thing with this defense though
is it's really unnatural to find which
is probably why he's looking at the
bishop which would just be a free Bishop
um but it's very scary to want to Castle
towards a position kind of feeling going
towards the danger but it's very
important that QD finds this is kind of
the only way to not give White
absolutely I'm scared oh okay
I'm scared
he's looking at a trade that's just
losing material for life
clean it up
even though now cutie is
maybe if she can find this Castle later
activator Bishop she can get her pieces
into the game then it won't be so
one-sided
he decided to take the pawn and now I'm
scared of those Falls in front of the
King opening up Andrea you think Papa
plot might walk into a mate on G2
I've seen a lot of those trackmates
lately I don't there's the go-to pogg
James mate the only thing is if he does
try really the most clear way would be
bringing the queen and the queen is
defending a maid of her own
that is true that is true that actually
might happen imagine the queen comes up
and cutie just forgets about Queen takes
D7 chalk mate that's why she meets the
castle and she does okay now she can
activate her Queen she could double the
Rooks this is game changing oh I didn't
realize we're blundering up on never
mind
but this this is scary it's honestly I
feel safer for Cutie's Kings here than
there because the Knight can always come
to B8 and create a little Shield
it's just cool when people Queen side
castle if you like people Queen side
over inside are just 10 times cooler
no I agree I think that you're
automatically cool with your queen for
that
absolutely but I'm really scared about
her King right now I mean yes the Knight
can move to ba but like The Rook on D1
looking towards Cutie's Rook I mean
everything is right now in this position
kind of kind of hanging and right now
Papa Platt does have his G2 Pawn
defendant so there's no Checkmate yet
dude there's some some crazy moves like
Papa plot he played a similar move last
game where he went oh the queen would
take never mind I was gonna say Knight
B5 where the pawn can't take threatening
mate right now the queen is defending
but or even Rook B1 there's literally so
many ways to threaten mates because his
Bishop is holding G2 right now
yeah yeah and I think he likes it you
know going for checkmates in one which
is a great tactic in poktown so we're
gonna see if he doesn't let's see if
cutie like what she's thinking
oh my God my eyes
if you guys use eyes give me a nodders
in chat if your eyes ever get so dry you
can't see straight and it's like no
matter how many eye drops you put in no
matter how much water you drink your
eyes are just like it's having a day
they didn't think of the 29. but imagine
she just wins two games in a row being
as sick as she is that that would
be a flex
that would be amazing that would be a
great story
wins this game I will deliver her eye
drops eye drops
yeah you should do that you should
deliver like some like cupcakes and
stuff too yeah well the thing is she's
always making cupcakes she probably
doesn't like eating her work I mean oh
yeah true true she's like really good at
baking stuff so maybe don't bake them
under it because probably
poison her and make her even worse wait
yeah I don't care what she's saying out
of this he might win oh wait oh no that
okay he's threatening mate in one
she needs to stop it she needs to see it
and she needs to stop it she was saying
a way out of this I was assuming you
here oh I do this okay oh
oh boy ah that pawn on C6 is gonna fall
oh gosh she's just in such a dangerous
position like all he needs to do is take
that pawn
yeah and he did it like immediately like
you saw that pawn and it was like I'm
gonna take it queen queen B7 is a
Checkmate right now um and I don't
really I can't really see how to stop it
I mean you have Knight C5 but Knight C5
Queen A8 there's so many scary moves
right now Andrea I don't think there is
a way to stop it I mean yeah she could
try delaying the mates and then escaping
them
oh go go
I'm sure oh God
yes
it's over man
okay I don't know I thought for a second
one
yeah
there it is oh man how do you say quotes
okay
yeah and I mean
it's uh sad or good to say I don't know
depending on who you're rooting for but
the fact that Papa plate chai is telling
me that you pronounced the e at the end
I'm so sorry I haven't done it I'm so
sorry
I'm very bad at pronouncing this name
um but anyways now Papa plate is going
to be going to the championship bracket
because he took you to Cinderella to the
tie Breakers and it will end up being a
point up in the final standings you know
no matter what happens here so cutie is
going to be going to the constellation
bracket but it's gonna be really fun to
see these tie Breakers what did you
think about the games under it looks so
good in the beginning I thought cutie
was gonna make it yep even though
Cutie's fate is determined meaning she's
not going to championships but Papa
plate is we still have one more game it
was 1-1 and you know this game is just
for the ego and for respect and I still
would like them to take this game
seriously and maybe cutie could avenge
herself
I think so too I think that they really
should do it and it always feels really
good obviously to win a chess so cutie
she's gonna have the white pieces now
and that is determined by the accuracy
of the two previous games now um the
tiebreaker is going to be one game and
it's gonna be three minutes plus five
seconds per move and now if that would
be a draw as well then they would be
doing another game and you know it would
keep on going like that all night long
if that would be the case would be you
know hyping It Up All Night Long Andrea
yup Chad is putting points on the line
there is there is still things on the
line for this game Anna you know don't
go way too soon chat let's see cutie
with the playing down at like 10 Health
right now would be cool to see
for sure no I I think that she's been so
strong she's playing right now on you
know bad health and that is a very hard
thing to do so I think their game is
going to start in just a second Andrea I
really hope to see some Revenge here you
know for Cutie now that she's sick and
everything let's see if how the game
goes and it's gonna go really fast
yep Chad how's Papa plate in faster time
controls he is very sharp when he can
take his time but this is a different
territory that we haven't seen him play
in yet so and I'm not trying to be
biased chat he is the crown Champion all
right we're gonna be rooting for him in
the championship it's this match is over
pretty much so you know there's got to
be something else we're looking forward
to to make this competitive okay
exactly exactly not well all right well
and this might be more of a fair match
okay what is this app for he's he uh or
no cutie keeps on going for this kind of
Stonewall setup that she's been kind of
liking yeah it's her go-to opening
Um Papa plot always chooses whether to
go copycat or whether to do something of
his own I just thought today looks like
he is playing his own opening
I love that he is doing his own thing
which is always really fun to see
although it's been fun to see some
copycat lines as well I always wonder
who's going to be the first person to
stop copycatting yeah um all fun and
games until you see two London games in
a row with the same position and now I
understand my viewers pain so
I've seen some London hate during uh
during POG Champs under I was hearing a
little rant the other day on how much
people hate the London well but we've
seen a lot of it
yeah that that is fair I have to say
Paul Champs has kind of changed my
opinion on the London I enjoy more when
the games are just more exciting when
Morris more stuff is happening the
positions open it's not symmetrical this
game is looking whoa is cutie gonna try
to set up the same mate again because
she might just get it two games in a row
it might be I mean queen H5 after those
night moves that might be insane okay
let's see what cutie is uh or no sorry
let's see what Papa Platt is saying yes
and if it's seeing it
dude
the amount of times people for all for
the same thing in Pogba foreign
maybe me like 100 fries
me too and my parents always get mad
okay cutie has to go G6 there's two
threats oh boy not one there's one on H7
and F7
and he just fell for this so he's gonna
know and he does he did it he went G6
you know no questions asked he knows
what's going on but there's still the
idea of going Queen H6 and then bringing
up the Knight to try to Checkmate on H7
so cutie can still got the get the H7
mate going on if she wants to bro what
the exactly
holy
okay and this is the position right now
so we're seeing the players of playing
moves pretty fast but now Cutie's
opening sorry Papa Platt is opening up
on the king's side and this can get a
little bit scary
is I she didn't find that mating net on
G7 but this is also very strong which is
why the eval bar is nearly touching the
sky right now there's a weak Pawn on F6
all of Cutie's pieces are pointed
towards the king like this is just a
beautiful position
yeah literally everything I'd be
terrified right now if I was Papa plate
I'd be absolutely terrified
okay I think this is good
yep looking towards this Pawn on E6
hey cutie just
the queen is trapped but it's so hard to
see I didn't even realize that the queen
was trapped let's go tune in to Papa
plot it's very unlikely but damn that
would be cool there's been so many free
Queens on the board but I haven't seen
them get taken yet okay never mind
a dog too fast you jinxed foreign
it's hard to see those open files
The Rook is too far away he sees them
now
oh no he doesn't you see something just
not the free room
what does cutie see it
again
the Cutie is the killer with the white
pieces
she's playing very strong I mean the
attack
okay you have seen The Rook now
the truth is
open files you really gotta whoever's
teacher needs to ingrain them into his
brain they're very important
here we got cutie
I don't think I know
this
uh
but the thing about cutie you know
bringing that Checkmate home now is the
real challenge so I'm just gonna go down
here real quick
true it is but there's a lot of pieces
on the board right now I trust her on
this one I don't know why not I don't
know if you saw what I saw yesterday but
it's true the only shot is like if she
somehow a Trapper Queen but it's you're
just too over here oh really so I'm
already in losers
great then I'll beat oh no she just
realized that she can't make it
this game still matters to us cutie we
want to see you redeem yourself and you
have so far
absolutely and now she's winning at
she's winning at night if she wants to
yep
so solid under Ash it's just like doing
all the good moves
yeah
simultaneously pulling off her forehead
with her actual vinegar I'm pumped
you should double the Rooks here double
the Rooks and set up a nice mate
that works too
it must be apple juice though right
it was like apple cider vinegar
oh do you drink that uh you sometimes
trying to do all the health hacks
oh I didn't know that I've never had
that welcome to America Anna we drink
anything and everything
okay we don't do this in Sweden you know
yeah well you guys are just healthy you
don't need it it's okay what is it it's
emergency ginger tea it's something well
oh there's this works too there was a
nice Bishop pin on the night but this is
also good let's just see just goes here
I would like her to bring in her
otherwise myself
me too I'm a little bit scared about
maybe the king moving to F7 there we go
like threatening The Rock and the wreck
not having a lot of places to go where
she blunders the bishop I mean she can't
blunder so many pieces right now like
she needs to keep it all together well
her clicking okay beautiful
okay very nice very nice I was worried
she was just touching those two pieces
sometimes when you're attacking you
forget to bring in the rest of your
pieces but she has to remember
exactly we gotta bring in everyone
everyone needs to join the party
I think she's got this under I think I
think she's got this I 100 believe I
ain't cutie right now
that was a nice move by Papa plot he is
not giving up this battle he is true he
is trying to disconnect the Rooks and
right now Cutie's Rook only has one
square to go E7 however he doesn't have
another piece to attack it with so it's
not so clear oh they would leave the
bishop hanging
but she's about to take with the wrong
Rook okay he needs to take with the Rook
from E1
because that Bishop is pinned yeah
she saw it I'll lose it second idea will
she do it
but then he just stays there oh no she's
going out for a different idea well then
I just lose this no she saw it but she
dismissed it too early do this
don't forget the Rook is hanging she
wants to make it work
so the secret here is leaving The Rook
on yep because right now it's hitting
that
and using the other roof and she has
blundered a rook
she has yeah she forgot out the record
was the nice idea yeah he doesn't take
it
Dumbo Mumbo
it's gonna be scary Andrea he saw the
bishop pinning the night and it got
scary
wait
he doesn't know can I just go here
wait this is there's a tactic here
that's probably oh my God I'm running a
Time
oh my God oh my gosh 20 seconds
oh I hope she doesn't flag okay she has
it still works she's just like luckily
she just walked into this beautiful
Discovery where she got two pieces for
her wait no she didn't she lost the
bishop
but she's still got two extra pieces
she's up yes exactly
she hasn't thrown the advantage she's
pre-pooving which um wow okay oh
and like really good feelings what's
going on here yeah taking away the
squares from the King
okay that was nice
there was a chance where Papa plate
could have taken her Rook but it's gone
now and now this is Cutie's game
absolutely the only thing I can see that
could get like a little bit you know
exciting is if the Rooks would get
swapped under that and we would get a
knight and Bishop end game I mean it
should be winning but like if all the
pawns are traded
and cutie does love to trade pawns that
one I remember I didn't learn that
Checkmate that Checkmate is like beyond
the elementary you learn you know mating
with the Rooks mating with the queen but
it takes a long time to learn how to
mate with the knight in Bishop it's not
as easy as it looks like
you know it now I do my dad forced me to
learn it but I haven't ever really had
an IRL game where I've needed to use it
okay okay
yes I'm great at the night
right the one yeah the one thing of my
dad's old school teaching oh my okay
wait we're fine I thought she was
blundering you're making me redo the
same thing over and over and over again
but I maybe forgot it who knows
oh wow even Hikaru failed it again okay
I'm back up on time someone else
it's not easy I mean uh next time I see
you Andrea you can please let me test
you I'll quiz you I'm a proud
okay cutie can set up a mate here yeah
unfortunately it's there's a lot of
Pawns and she's pushing them and it
doesn't look like he's gonna be able to
trade
so this is the current position we have
right now actually cutie was able to get
a lot of time she has over a minute now
like it looked really scary before but
now this Pawn this age Pawn seems to be
a winner I mean she's gonna promote it
and I'm sure that she'll promote it now
to a queen
um I I saw the little Auto promotion
thing going on yesterday but now I'm
sure this will be a queen yeah luckily
there's two pieces that can move on the
board so it doesn't matter what she will
promote to there won't be a stalemate
again
no I mean there's no way there's a still
made again and this King uh her King
cannot get checkmated in any way either
everything is under control so I fully
trust that she will win this Yep this
this is a Victorious win but reminder
Chad Papa plate is still going to the
championship after this so it's kind of
Bittersweet but I feel like this was the
best ending for Cutie after that loss
she came back and played a beautiful
game with the white pieces
exactly and you know maybe she will do
amazing in the constellation bracket so
I mean there's always a good story you
know exactly that could be her bracket
okay so I'm just looking for still mates
but you know there's still Peppa Plaza
still has that pawn I hope she doesn't
take it
okay do we have a ladder Checkmate
Andrea kind of
yeah no I learned um a very cool Strat
from cutie on her most recent ladder
mate she likes to do with the
unconventional way
yeah
one okay she's um I don't know why we
Bishop the bishop was defending the
queen to come in
okay she's taking pawns I don't like it
when cutie big is a freaking pong I'm
getting a little bit worried here but
he's doing the same
uh if he could get his Rook to C3 but
it's not obvious how Okay Okay kitties
oh
she's going for the Honda I mean his
Pawn is getting closer and closer to the
first rank this is getting scary but all
she needs to do is attack the pawn and
then the Rook can't defend yeah now now
it's gonna be a check that was it yep
there we go all right Chuck made in one
after this King A1 rookie eight
Checkmate you know she's gonna
questionable maneuver but it worked
nice
oh
but now I can go back this way
oh yeah no okay there we go nice Beauty
with not one but two checkmates today
quite a stark opposite from yesterday
and we're happy to see it I did it very
happy to see it no matter what even if
Cutie's not making now the championship
bracket she still fought so well being
sick and she did amazing you know with
two checkmates so she does win the match
so big clap to cutie for winning the
match even if it was after tie breaks
2-1 and big clap to Papa plate as well
for going into the championship I think
he's gonna be a very strong contender in
there we have you know Sea Dog my
students ghastly staff nap and I would
maybe not take down my students but I'd
like to see them go face to face
I knew you were gonna bring up your
students now you know that's why you
started this whole thing oh you know
it's just Championship bracket Champions
Make Champions and we've got another one
today
I was speaking of Champions Chad is
saying X is still sleeping we he is the
next game of today I think we're gonna
do a little interview
um I don't know if he's gonna wake up
but we are relying on him making it to
the match chat
I'm sure he will wake up there's no way
he would miss it right Andrea there's no
way there's no no
he went gave a very long speech
yesterday about how he's taking this
very seriously and he's studying offline
and he's gonna show up too late for the
championship and he has never wanted to
win more so there's no way no way that
would happen this is it xqc versus
tyler1 I mean he really wants to win so
let's go ahead and check out the group
standings over here because Group D is
finished we got all the points I did a
thing ended up on Seven Points winning
the whole bracket which is I mean
amazing like I did a thing I didn't know
that he played so much chess but he just
came in here and just beat everyone
pretty much no I I got to see his games
yesterday for the first time in the
tournament and he very much impressed me
I did a thing versus Papa plot would be
a great a great match to see
absolutely that would be really fun we
got Papa Platt now finishing on six
points in uh it's number two and then
cutest Cinderella and then firstly at
the very end with one point but she did
end up getting her point so we are going
to be getting uh some interviews very
soon Andrew are we getting them now are
we going to break I think we're going to
go in a short break and then we're gonna
return to you guys with a very much
awaited interview with pup plate we're
gonna see just how good his English is
because our German's not very good it's
terrible we will see you very soon don't
miss the interview hear these little
faint victory cheer was so sad
that little fist bump
oh
you guys play chess you want to talk
about it let's do oh yeah where do you
play chess at you know okay when I say
chess the first word that pops into your
mind
protect my queen Hikaru intelligence
strategy tactics Toby Maguire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice if you're on
Tinder and you're scrolling and someone
has a chess player on their profile as
that swipe left or swipe right
Play Bright is good right yeah then yeah
instant swipe right okay super into that
right I'm into it you're ready probably
whatever the swipe is I don't not
interested you're not interested in
chess players I'm not into chess players
around Tinder oh I get that in fact that
checks out if I ask you to name one
chess player in the world can you name a
chess player
if you name five other world champions
in the next 15 seconds I'm Gonna Give
You fifty dollars
dude oh my God we just lost 50 whose
idea was that
[Music]
what is the banished Gambit game one or
game two game one game one no please
don't it's too soon Hikaru we didn't
even reach a climax yes yes yes
exactly what we practice for
this is the best player in his group so
I thought I thought he played um
don't go King at five don't go king of
five stalemate
oh no
oh two seconds on the clock
yeah baby there it is big win big points
oh my God can we be two Checkmate
checkmate
that's fine
you're yelling it's like you didn't
expect
good move by him so you need to keep the
Rook on the a file to so you don't drop
your passport
oh god there goes the other Rook yeah I
I think he didn't see that but the king
is close enough to the pawn where we're
gonna be able to capture and this will
be a force draw
oh my gosh oh man and now no mouse
slipped by Ruby it's just Queen V8
instead of Queen B7 and um then that's
game over oh my gosh she might have this
is crazy he stopped at B oh he's going
the other way oh no he missed it very
nice wow
so clean
wow
amazing let's do this let's do the
respectful thing
easy
boys we're editing
[Music]
thank you
let's go
[Music]
this up
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we just saw cutest Cinderella beat Papa
plate 2-1 but she's still going to the
constellation bracket and papa plate is
making it to the championship bracket
now we've got cutest Cinderella here who
uh how are you feeling cutie you won
you're you're sick how did it feel to
play like this oh I don't feel good
I I I I did my best I don't feel good
I'm so sick
um but that's okay I have like just like
a massive headache which is the worst
kind of sick to have for chess
um but I've got ginger tea and I didn't
throw up during this so you know what
that's a win
yeah first we just want to say sorry
someone's in my ear okay first we just
want to say how much we appreciate you
for showing up today because yeah we can
hear your voice we see you sipping
liquids you're not feeling the best but
ironically it was some of your best
chests that I've ever seen
sorry it's amazing
uh sorry hey holler I I hear you by the
way oh sorry go ahead I just couldn't
hear anything
um but oh sorry Anna go ahead sorry it
threw me off guard did they say it was
amazing like that 20 move check made in
the beginning cutie that was incredible
is this like your specialty uh to go for
the Stonewall line where you just lock
everything in
oh yeah that's this that's the classic
stone wall right there that's where I
actually usually never gonna pull it off
um but he let me follow like verbatim I
think I think I did the Stonewall almost
verbatim
yeah have been very strong game after
game
the second game but I I forgot to take
the piece
I realized it was a tricky game
that's all right
his Checkmate was tricky too
yeah well you know you're very two trick
twice and it was nice to see but um so
now you're going into the consolation
bracket is there anyone you're looking
forward to taking on
um I am I'm excited do I do I get to
play everyone how does it work
so you're gonna be playing everyone in
the bottom bracket so there's saikudo
daily dose of Internet Ginny hopefully
you're not playing foosli again and then
after those the rest on your group is
Jarvis virtual and squeaks which are
some very serious competition
I would love to play squeaks if I could
choose anyone it would be squeaks
why is that
because he's bad
because he's simply he's simply not good
you know I have to say squeaks is
probably the nicest purchase and
everyone xqc was roasting the out
of him I don't know what he's done to
deserve all this slender he seems like a
very nice lad he was that he was at my
house
he was at my house for like uh a weekend
or something and we were both sitting on
the couch and just playing chess against
each other
just back and forth and whenever we're
beating him we would have to do 10
push-ups no he stayed with me a few
times and we he beat me a few times too
but I like putting push-ups on the line
yeah we put push-ups on the line we put
levy on the TV and then Levy was being
annoying and distracting us so we had to
stop watching Levy and go back to
playing but we tried that was our
practice but I feel like I've practiced
more so I'm ready to I'm ready to take
him down
that is amazing is there anyone else
that you uh that you're scared of
playing or someone that you're scared of
playing in the in the Constitution her
student cutie I think that's what she
wants I already watched I'm trying to
get it out yeah I don't want to play war
tool I don't want it there you go Anna
here which um
he's playing oh yeah yeah go ahead he
just he grinds so hard on everything he
does he's like
Omega nerd
right she has got some chests on her TV
well that that is true but you know some
people like put got some chess on TV so
people grind eye roll which I guess Q to
you the two so I can't even say that but
yeah I did but you've been playing so
well at cutie like which um cutie yeah
speaking of training so have you been
doing any secret chess lessons with
Gotham chess or you just like his
annoying voice in the background of your
living room I I have not done a lesson
with him since I think 2021.
ah so you know just a little bit of time
are you yeah how sweaty you're gonna
take the consolation bracket do you want
to do any lessons or you want to just
shine
more than willing
I just need to know I don't know what
I'm playing
don't worry we will get on that
um but that's good to know there's a lot
of amazing coaches me Anna Nemo all the
chess streamers and we would love to do
some lessons oh dude absolutely always
um well we are kind of stalling for xqc
to wake up so um
have you ever beat Ludwig in chess
you're supposed to thank me for coming
on
oh is it over I can hear him yeah thank
you guys perhaps it's not working we
don't hear anything we don't hear
anything right now yeah thank you for
coming you're amazing for playing
tassels you're sick have a great one
thank you so much
excuse yourself
hmm
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
am I pronouncing your name right
everyone is saying that I keep on
pronouncing it wrong
no no it's very good for uh not German
it's it's no joke very very very good
it's in Germany we say papa plaza but
there are also some Germans who can't
pronounce it so it's fine no problem
it's very very good Papa plate
it's very sharp
chat was hyped
thank you I thought we couldn't
communicate but um there is a question
that I've been asking and as you show up
on our stream everyone is spamming xqc
maybe for different reasons but how do
you feel about being called the German
xqc
I mean I mean I guess it's fine right
after uh uh we beat him in our place
even I I the German community say he is
more like the the German like the
Canadian power plant now you know you've
got him yep yeah yeah yeah yeah but uh
that's great I mean I I like the stream
and uh yeah I guess he's a bit of an
inspiration
that's actually very sweet what do you
think of his chest so far if you guys
were to go head to head
oh I don't know I I haven't seen him uh
playing much chess so far I mean uh I
guess yes neither have us he uh he
didn't appear to like two or three
matches so far
yeah
definitely showing up today so yeah
he put on a suit
the trash
[Music]
all over hours interest in me so maybe
he's a bit better
he's been playing really well and he's
been really proud of having uh no
mistakes dude actually I'm gonna ask you
do you think he's gonna show up today
no you should have like I don't think so
that's well that means we're just gonna
stall your interview for a very long
time which I didn't want to ask you so
what is your chest history I know you've
done maybe a twitch Rivals before but
what made you want to play in POG Champs
[Music]
oh it's so long uh ago I'm not I'm not
pretty sure I guess it started all with
the puck Champs the first one I guess oh
because you did play before I forgot uh
yeah I started uh playing with when I
was nine or something with my neighbor
but like just the rules and the the
basic stuff and
um yeah after that didn't play for a
long time and then when I started
streaming the bottom stuff uh started
and
I guess Ludwig asked me or something I'm
not pretty sure it's it's so long ago it
doesn't remember him
but yeah then I started a chess coach
ing the Big Greek watching your games
this year yeah exactly yeah we sometimes
uh practice I had the Ludwig um
uh had an event whereas chess boxing and
I trained for this yeah you were
supposed to do this box thing yeah yeah
yeah but I couldn't participate because
my ear I'm not sure how it's called in
English but my the drum in my ear is
like
oh boy that's terrifying oh no yeah are
you raving in Berlin or what what did
you do gaming hard how did you you sit
out of PC for a living what'd you do I
was I was in the back home and uh like
uh yeah we had a sparring I'm surprised
they let you in I'm just kidding
well maybe this is prepped for a future
chest box they would love to see
maybe maybe I would uh I would be done I
guess
I will be done
so how does it feel that you're you know
making it to the championship bracket
did you expect to do it did you expect
to get there uh
uh no no I'm I'm I'm very proud of it
somehow and I'm not pretty sure how I
did it because I haven't practiced at
all I started practicing two hours
before the first match
well I don't know I don't know how I did
it
and and the very important question
let's say somehow a miracle happens the
Big Greek is doing lessons and you're
making it into the finals are you you
have a lot of distance to travel similar
to some of our other competitors Connors
from Japan you obviously don't live in
the states will you come to La for your
final chess match which is actually
would be in 15 days if you clean up the
swedes I guess I guess uh it doesn't
matter if I uh come so far or not
because uh I'm I'm I'm I'm not I'm not
available in this time I can't say much
about it because
I don't know why I asked no no it's fine
it's fine it's fine just tell us that
you're gonna beat the competition You're
Gonna Come face to face and beat xqc and
you're very excited to come to America
I'm very excited to come to America
yes good that's the spirit
for you
um and one thing only and I
and I to know
what is what is your I8 what does this
mean yeah I also want to know
okay I'm very intrigued I guess I guess
I can't tell it on stream
it's it's for the better I mean you're
ready for Future travel I don't think
you have a choice you can just you know
I mean there was like kind of an
incident while I was driving
and
um
foreign
trust me
have you ever played um IRL chess in
Germany because obviously chess is much
more popular in Europe and there's
there's some great chess clubs in
Germany
oh it is it is more popular in Germany
in Europe or just in Europe in general
uh last year my sister and I did a show
and we went to Berlin well we were not
really there for chess but we did some
chess meetups and anywhere I go outside
of the US people come up and play our
little chess and they have chess bars
and everything have you seen this at all
in Germany or no
uh uh
like uh my mom gifted me a chess set for
my birthday and for my last birthday a
very sick one
um
but
but yeah I guess I haven't played that
much IRL chess because all of my friends
uh are
and then it's not it's not that much fun
you know
yeah you're not very good at making
friends just beating them up
yeah so
one uh final question as well
um that chat was asking are you ready
for the finals are you gonna beat
everyone at the finals how are you
feeling are you ready
for Championship bracket
yeah for a championship bracket exactly
for the next bracket yeah I'm very
excited I hope I uh it's my next game um
versus HTC or Tyler
yeah right yeah yeah yeah I think
totally six I have no idea
right okay I have an idea between who
wins what you versus xqc loser has to
dye their hair a different color because
there can't be two oh there can only be
one and who did this first because
yesterday
we're wearing a hat but you show you
yesterday I was like he even has that
xqc of hair like he's really trying to
rock the whole German xpc thing or or
the non-american xcc yeah we had to we
had to try for us when our place uh was
a thing last week because rubius the
um ah there's a third one there's so
many yeah yeah yeah
it was crazy but um yeah I thought about
going back to my natural color so
yeah maybe I'm down for what is that
color if I lose uh like this what is
your initial color
the brown that dark brown Kinders
yeah that would be a good way to assert
dominance
maybe that's how you show you're better
than them only I thought you would look
great and blue
yeah I'm not sure
I'm not sure but yeah I'm very happy
that I'm in the championship bracket
let's see
America
yeah and I'm very happy America
[Laughter]
all right we're gonna let you go very
quickly uh because we're very soon gonna
have another interview with tyler1 and
that's gonna be very exciting so we're
gonna go on a super short break and
we're gonna get an interview with Tyler
thank you so much Papa plate for joining
us and good luck in the championship
bracket you're gonna do great
thank you bye bye guys
bye
normal
let's go
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
there anyway
s
[Music]
foreign
thank you
uh toddler two foot yeah he's done oh
yeah the guy's like I think the guy's
sub 100 rated
yeah he's that I think he should be back
as an adult if you played that bad the
system should should say that you're not
you're not even trying to win the game
and you're ruining the expense of other
people you're he's so bad
I'm sorry elevation have been allowed
him yeah I think it's just that bad
we are back with the most anticipated
match of the night xqc versus tyler1 I
am so excited for this one I'm joined
but with Andrea bothas Andrea how
excited are you to see this matchup this
is a very insane matchup and what's even
more insane is the fact that xqc has
woken up we see him bright and early on
his stream where lad was just saying
that he slept on the floor so you know
thanks for still coming well meanwhile
on the other side there's Tyler one very
upset that xqc is late seems like
chess.com is against him first that
Ginny lag now this X game is Tyler gonna
rise up against the Rings
that is the question but wow I mean
there's been some beef here Andrea
hasn't there yeah no one could even
argue you know I really don't think it
was this thought out but um sometimes
top chess players show up a little bit
late to their games to play mind games
on their opponent something that Tyler I
quote was saying Magnus curls thin does
so maybe this was just a giant mind game
but I I have a feeling it was not
I have no idea but that would be a maybe
a very smart move by xqc to be honest
but I do feel bad that he's been
sleeping on the floor I hope that you
know his his brain and all of him is
ready now for this big game against
China One and I'm also excited to see
what oh here we are
making the piss now guys
this is a disrespectful piss someone
punish it look Tyler if you beat xcc you
guys are face to face in the live finals
meeting up in LA to play chess you know
you can show them your guns and teach
him a lesson just kidding don't do that
I want to see can I really want to see
xqc versus tyler1 in the finals I mean I
know that might be hard but that would
be absolutely amazing Andrea like I
would fly from Sweden to L.A to watch
that I promise you that hundred percent
if we see that but if anything Chad has
a point SEC is winning these Mind Games
Tyler has to stay focused and ready to
show up because suc has a lot of rating
on him and even though Tyler only lost
one game quote because he Mouse slipped
you know could have been a mouse club I
don't know there was a lot of mouth
slips on Tyler's games a lot of mistakes
happening because of the mouse slips
um this is gonna be his most advanced
opponent yet it's not going to be an
easy match
no I mean xqc has been playing really
well I am very very very surprised on
you know how much he's improved and I
mean he hasn't really made a lot of
mistakes so it's gonna be really fun to
see how it goes against Tyler one will
tyler1 be able to pull his famous
trackmate on xqc or not I don't know but
it's gonna be really exciting to see
that there's there's a lot of pressure
on the line for Tyler not only does he
have to win this game but in his champ
what does it have a door he just has a
wall that he hides by I just really cut
me off guys he's just gonna go take his
Adderall he has to get Juiced up okay
which I don't I don't know if this
should be allowed there should be some
punishments but look I don't make the
rules I don't even I mean Tyler should
also then then go and get two stuff I
guess but I feel like this Tyler's just
naturally Juiced up he just shows up and
that's it maybe a little bit of
pre-workout powder you know I'm pretty
sure he must have done a little bit of a
pre-workout uh right before that I
wonder if he did his pump before this
game of chess
I feel like that could help you know no
other routines are right now but it does
feel like xqc just woke up so we will
see a little bit how it goes but there's
a big rating difference Andrea in this
match yes speaking of rating difference
this is what I wanted to say not only is
this Tyler's first first very difficult
challenging match but after this in the
championship bracket people are almost a
whole 1 000 points above him which not
saying that Tyler has an underdog can't
take him but there's there's a lot of
pressure
but I gotta say that just shows how
impressive it is that he's made it to
the championship bracket because let's
make that clear that both of these
players are now in the championship
bracket and they're going to be fighting
against some really strong players later
on so it's very impressive that Tyler
one was able to do this and I'm super
happy to see him in POG champs this year
to be honest I have to say I totally
agree he was doing a little bit of Chess
between but he didn't take much lessons
and the fact that he was cleaning up his
group is very nice to see I like to see
it because you know as Tyler Tyler says
they hate to see him win
he's been thinking that that the
commentators here have been biased
against him so I don't know Andrea maybe
we should Tyler up a little bit you know
speaking of bias Anna whose side are you
on today you know we got to be the
biased commentators that we are you
gotta take a side okay well I gotta be
honest here I always root for the
underdie I like seeing an Underdog Story
so I would be happy seeing Tyler one
doing yeah winning this game to be
honest
now we found Kitty Cinderella's eye drop
um all right well xqc is awake you know
I just had haven't seen it yet but I
heard that he can see the pieces better
actually
oh wow
well Andrea who are you rooting for are
you gonna be uh taking my side or the
opposite side you know it's hard because
there is a clear favorite but xqc has
been talking a lot of game yesterday
well you know he did slander my DJ set
but aside from that he said that he did
make a single mistake he's undefeated
which is all very true but I think we've
been kind of boosting his ego like
carrying him against weaker players so
even though he's been he's been very
strong I want to see him been put to the
test so we're both rooting against them
oh no no no no no no well you know it's
hard for me to root for him after
yesterday but you know I'll read for how
about the better player let's see who
she plays better on the board May the
better player win also
um guys we cannot hear excuses uh stream
I don't know if we're supposed to but
it'd be cool yep yep since the game is
starting wait is tyler1 doing it doing a
cow no no there's no way that Tyler is
doing cow opening right now right this
is the start
all right we're bringing in their audio
chat
the mind game is right there this
is absolutely amazing no I am definitely
beautiful
yeah the big cow energy apparently he
was prepping it that's pretty cool
did they
I love it
let me think
he can get a lesson on the cow if he
wants to I'd be happy to give one
yeah speaking of the cow I was gonna say
run it down a bit angle this is working
it is honestly a good shot for you it's
very good for beginners because it's
very safe and it's hard to blunder
this is honestly amazing I can't believe
that the cow has made it into POG Champs
to be honest
wait can we uh tune in to xqc chat I
don't know I'm asking chat I mean Mr
Producer
run it down mid that is the one thing
that I've learned about gaming that is
how Tyler plays chess running it down
mid and playing the Cowboys
um
I don't know how to develop pumpkin I'm
gonna be honest with you I don't know
how to developer I have no idea
I could go like this
I don't know if he just woke up but
but sounded a little bit but I'm just
guessing it's probably because he just
rolled out of bed
yeah not particularly well though
and say it doesn't know how to develop
this has to get his Bishop out it's a
great position
I know you're a hater of the cow opening
Andrea I've heard that so the one thing
I was gonna say but it
very sneaky Bishop though you see the
Knight coming up as well
uh uh the knights oh the night coming to
F4 wait wait H4 he does that right
something bad
I don't know if he sees what you season
but
I hope he doesn't move it back though
because his Bishop is gonna get trapped
oh is X gonna push G4 it's not super
easy to see but this is what I'm gonna
say about the cow you punish them pieces
they're going back you capitalize on
this
oh but Tyler is also keeping the
pressure on the knife if xqc doesn't
push this and maybe he does what Anna
says
he takes this no
T4 and the bishop is trapped Mr Krishna
in chat
yeah the the funny thing is that it's
actually the fact that you play the cow
that's the reason this bishop is trapped
because he can't move it back anymore
some point during the week while you
cringers were backseat gaming I was
gonna say
unlikely all right and he doesn't trap
the bishop
oh Bishop he blenders
my God is Tyler gonna see it
it's a free Bishop this is huge this
could be huge and it's such a natural
move to just take the bishop you see
something and you take it well after
Tyler has to do is take it and he's up
all right that was the first blunder we
should get a blunder counter for how
many we think we'll see this game
um
oh Andrea I already thought he had it
there imagine imagine immediately
winning a piece that would be yeah
incredible that would have been like a
huge Advantage straight out of the
opening but not happening ladies and
gentlemen it is equal
under the bishop again the bishop is
right now I mean it can just be taken at
this moment in time Knight takes bishop
and xqc cannot take it back because the
queen is hanging with excuses wonder the
queen right here Tyler is taking a
hugely adversity you see up a whole
piece
if he takes it with it I get Queens
he sees the pin he Tyler rising up to
xqc's level and maybe even better
I think he just like I think he just
likes the cow he understands it
you know this wasn't supposed to happen
but all the credits if I take this I
lose my queen
nice
xpc has to keep the pressure now he has
to get another piece to come back in
this game
yeah this is now a tricky moment because
at this moment Tyler needs to see Knight
takes F3 pretty much uh so that he
doesn't understand if Bishop takes off
seven would be played or something then
for free it doesn't matter it is trapped
it yeah
Yep this is why you always have to look
for forcing moves let's see I like that
Tyler is taking his time I think I trade
for his Knight
oh my God he's playing amazing
no no
no no it's not that he's gonna take
as long as it doesn't it doesn't matter
what he thinks I ran away
what if I ran away so it's a one for one
trade
wow dude we didn't get to finish the
rest of his calculation but he made the
right decision
and he's keeping the advantage very
strong play on Tyler's part
she's winning right now he's a full
piece up obviously at peace is maybe not
so much but I mean it's a full piece of
he's objectively winning he just needs
to keep his advantage and not playing
this but let's not forget what this is
ladies and gentlemen it is POG Champs
I've seen Tyler not take free Queens but
he has taken those checkmates so I don't
know how long this bishop will last
I'm honestly very impressed very
impressed good very good representation
for the cow Community though I have to
say I know this has been marketing
I didn't I didn't tell Tyler to do this
he just saw it he liked it and he did it
move some ponza boys
boys the march of the pawns begins we
are chill
I mean excuse me doesn't really seem
like he's too stressed about being a
piece down yet to be honest
yep I think he's he still hasn't
completely woken up
I think something's gonna kick in mid
gonna come to life
one two one
take take
uh who am I going to I'm just I am
pretend I can think when I'm not
what takes or is it seeing is it Knight
takes Bishop that he's calculating wait
you can let's tune in see his arrows
let's do this it's gonna be very hard
for white to break through but that's
the way to do it I'm gonna go open
looking up a little bit like it's gonna
make him vulnerable but I I have a nice
Rook here so I can kind of chill out
with it
really gets that diagonal but it is hard
to be the more attacking player when
you're down a piece no we're good but I
think he could out calculate this time
he got in a good position so
numbers I mean no it's only a piece at
the end of the day
it's only a minus three in in the world
where you're gonna use all your pieces
right and they're all gonna have a value
if you don't use your pieces then the
value so this is a rook as let me use in
the game yet it's that's five right
that's five that's ten it's not being
used so why am I still have a plus three
if there's a minister on that but I'm
not
all of these make sure I use it
yeah
all you gotta do is
um yes I think that here what what xqc
needs to do is like he needs to just
push and just try to create an insane
attack like open up over here open up
the G file and just try to get a queen
on G3 get the king up get a rook in and
just try to go for the G7 Pawn that's
what I think he needs to do right now to
get any chances it's a very ambitious
attack but I think he has what it takes
this is here
I think so too I mean it is a scary
attack although this is the famous
trackmate that Tyler has been doing
right with the queen of Rook lined up I
wouldn't fall for his own his own
medicine I don't think so I don't think
he would he's learned that one quite
well so it is a little bit risky that
Tyler is opening up his King but at the
same time xqc gets his King oh opened up
he didn't take but he's continuing to
pressure it this is still good
Tyler doesn't want to open up that file
it is going to be too dangerous
I don't know if I like that knife takes
takes a fork could happen
oh now what
hmm
so many decisions
take this
takes it
right don't take anything I think
Tyler's got this what does he do he goes
down what do you want Tyler to play it
takes that
and then I take it it's hard because
like I'm also scared of him like taking
a lot of stuff because then all the
pieces will be opened up but I like this
movie he's like we're moving the knight
from here this piece to finally maybe I
go here
there we go we were a little bit behind
in delay of course this piece out
exactly scared of Tyler trading pawns
and opening up the files because I think
if x gets an open file that is where he
will Thrive and he will attack towards
the king and it'll be very hard to
defend this is a good safe move kicking
out the night we want to provoke white
to trade pieces because Tyler's up a
whole feast and that night is a very
strong piece so actually a very well
calculated move on Tyler's part he's
playing extremely well I mean his rating
right now 229 does not reflect his
strength I feel like yeah no we used to
make fun of his little 200 rating but he
is playing so above his level I don't
know if he was really prepping hard
overnight right he just clearly was he
was watching your shorts on the cow but
he is like a new player today
yeah I know I think that the cow changed
them you know
so XTC is trading
meaning he just has a rook and queen to
attack with but he also has a lot of
space this Strat is very interesting all
he needs to do he's kicking out that
Bishop if Tyler misplays which he does
he has a free Pawn he just needs two
more pawns to equalize on the board and
now he has that explosive file Plateau
he does I don't like this move because
the bishop now is gonna be stuck like
over here if he would have moved the
other way the bishop at least would be a
little bit more free but now this bishop
is stuck so his extra piece doesn't
really do much
the beads are kicking in chat
the game is about to change
yeah but I you know I mean this doesn't
have to really like look at xqc's King
as well this is a fantastic move
targeting the pawn underground yep yep
he only has one two ways to defend with
his Queen
but still the good thing about this Pawn
structure is he's down but that Bishop
on H7 is kind of useless if Tyler wants
to activate the bishop he has to find
king h8 and then Bishop G8 it's not an
easy maneuver typically a bishop a very
long range piece you don't want it to be
blocked by a ton of Pawns where right
now it has literally no safe squares
yeah absolutely very true but now Tyler
gets back that pawn and I'm telling you
know he didn't defend no no the pawn is
gone and if this if excuses Queen moves
I mean Tyler's Queen is coming in and
the king is not gonna be safe at all so
Tyler is not playing like an underdog
right now he's seeing everything he came
so prepared today I mean I wonder what's
gonna happen if uh if he beat xqc to be
honest I I don't want to know honestly I
I'm if after that pencil snap I feel
like but this is good the reminder
there's two games if this is Tyler's
game it's just gonna make the second one
even more entertaining
absolutely there is one more game and I
do think that right now xkc is preparing
the battery with the rook and the queen
pointing towards G7 but it is a scary
strategy to do letting your own King be
a little bit vulnerable but it could
work it could work although it's easy to
defend
exactly like there is a clear threat but
it's clear for both sides and since
Tyler has been seeing everything it's
hard for me to believe that he won't see
a move like Rook F7 still Anything Can
Happen would be um a 10-0 or a 10. it's
a 10-5
anchors of five seconds on 10 minutes
I was not aware of this I didn't talk
about the format this is part three of
the long going Saga where POG champers
sign up for a chess tournament and don't
read any of the rules at all most of
them don't know the time control but all
his games has had an additional five
seconds per move however if he goes into
tiebreakers I think X wants to use his
advantage in Blitz chess which he could
but to do that he has to win a game at
least one
yep he does and look at Tyler I mean he
played very safe getting the Rook now
there's no way for xqc to Checkmate
he's sitting in the dark he's got that
he is very focused and I like to see it
that way he can't take this
I'm loving this this is amazing wow
like what x could try right now is a
very big battery where he doubles both
Rooks on the G file so bringing one to
G2 bringing the other one to G1 then
Tyler just goes between H6 that could
even be X's plan but Queen H6 and then
he defends it three times
yeah and there's nothing to do the only
thing scary I feel like is if Tyler
wouldn't know how to get his Bishop
around and if he would start going
something like G5 or G6 and open up the
G file just to get the bishop moving
then it could get really scary and it
looks like a pretty natural move if you
don't really know Pawn
oh no you did it
I was gonna say the only thing that
could go wrong is if Tyler breaks under
pressure he just needs to keep the solid
defense and not touch pawns that is the
worst thing he could do is push upon
right now otherwise he's completely
solid he can move any
other piece
all right this is gonna get very
dangerous for Tyler
I'm sorry and dry side I have a couple
moves hardly I'm so sorry I couldn't I
couldn't complain myself luckily he can
defend his Bishop takes he brings in The
Rook but he's he's making it hard for
himself but
they're still they're very solid defense
it's just gonna take a little bit more
calculation to spot
I think excuse he's coming back now
Andrea I think that this game just did a
180 turn or whatever you call it and now
it's
yep oh okay
oh wow this is crazy and we have traded
the pieces uh Tyler has given the bishop
right back and now we have equal Eyes On
The Board in a very exciting and even
end game which at the high level Grand
Masters would drop but at this level I'm
expecting a win
yeah I mean there's no way we see a rook
end game Draw over here I cannot believe
it I think that xqc's plan is going to
be to push his H Pawn because this is
one past Pawn he needs to try to push it
as far as he possibly can but end games
are hard and end games is not the first
thing you learn Bro
true
yeah keeps it defended
that was so smart
uh
it works it works there we go
it's working
oh nice sweet I guess there's a lot of
ways to push I was this was the more
tricky one but he saw the sack
oh now we just can't film it could there
be a stone made under I don't know why
he's going for the bonds
oh my God he's pre-moving Pond bushes
yeah
oh my God he's not oh that was way too
close for comfort
able
four minutes and 44 seconds why is he
pre-moving you have so much time
oh no no he got the Checkmate ah Tyler
could have went one squared up to make
it a little tricky that was
that was very very dangerous because if
he almost did one more pre-move it would
have been a stalemate
but it's not himself I thought we were
gonna get a stomach there Andrea that
was incredible but xqc wins the first
gaming as Tyler won after that crazy
opening where Tyler was just a piece up
he was completely winning but xqc was
able to trade pieces get the piece back
and then go into a winning pawning game
that was crazy though Andrea we saw a
pawn in game I mean how often do we see
this here that was pretty good yeah I
have to say once again props to Tyler
he's playing these very Advanced
positions for his level and the mistake
that he made is very common when you're
in a very blocked position and you're
close though that was I
absolutely
you push upon and you blunder this is a
very important lesson to learn
I totally agree but I do think you
should be happy with himself I mean he
proved that he can play a very solid
game against someone that's 800 points
pretty much higher rated than him so
that is absolutely amazing I think you
should be very proud of himself and I'm
proud of him for playing the cow hello
chat we have one more game from them
Tyler needs to win this one if he wants
a chance at taking home the dub so that
he can go into tiebreakers and if not
then all that they've been talking
there's gonna be a rightful winner
absolutely what do you think is going to
happen in game number two Andrea as much
I you know I want to be unbiased so I
would like to see them face off in a tie
breaker
okay well the game is gonna start in
just one second we're gonna see the game
right here I'm so excited to see if
tyler1 is able to make a comeback and
win this game or if xqc will go ahead
and win I'm also wondering you know what
what openings we're gonna see here under
Ed do you think we'll see another cow
you know X's openings are pretty solid
so I'm gonna say no I'm just kidding
um but I don't remember what x is
playing and I'm also very curious if
Tyler did any prep with the black pieces
but the fact that even prepped with the
white I was impressed because not a lot
of students have been taking it on their
own to prep oh my God the game has
started
Andrea dude if we get two cows in a row
yes
yes Anna you've created a monster I
don't know how you've done it but he is
Mr cows so it's only fair that he gets
to play the cow as well
let me just say something I did not tell
tyler1 to do this this is his choice he
saw this and he loved it and he wanted
to play it so I just inspired her with
something the truth is she's kind of
Genius so
oh my God so what's this cooldown period
I don't get time to cool down because he
was 30 minutes late
the
I don't have cooldown's the right term
but that's fair probably just the team
trying to start the game but I I get it
he's very competitive and there's a lot
on the line and I'm fine with that
should be competitive about this
for sure for sure and I think that it's
really annoying him that xqc is stopping
the cow from happening it's like XTC
knows what title wants to do
beatable for sure
this is very risky for white you better
pray you don't see me when the actual
bracket starts scrub ass just
imagine them showing up like Tyler
horrifying on the internet but I bet
money and if they were to show up in
person it'd be the nicest people ever
they'd shake hands nothing would happen
but who knows who knows
I want to see it though I wouldn't I
want to know to be honest
okay so here Knight of six is played xqc
is getting his night out but he's
allowing Tyler to pick up the bishop and
I mean obviously excuse you would be
able to take back but typically I mean
you don't really want to get rid of your
Bishop so early on so I think here
tyler1 should take the bishop although
it's also good to just obviously
continue with doing the cow just like
he's doing there I I support that yep I
see no one has learned the refutation
the the line that I Was preparing my
student what you need to do against the
cat which you know maybe I should just
unless he could shut
um
okay Tyler's doing very solid
development at least he's getting his
Bishops out
yep yep very solid I mean he could also
push the pawn by getting the bishop out
is also fine and now you should take
with the queen and I think now I mean
this is not such a bad position Andrea
his pieces have developed the bishop is
getting out he's getting Castle maybe
he'll Castle Queen side maybe we'll see
some fun like that I don't know but this
is a normal chest position
all right let's take a listening to Mr
Cowell
is Tyler gonna be excuses demise in this
game of chess
fun
we saw it immediately after
oh Justice I don't know how to use
Bishops though I don't know how to use
these so I need my rubs the only damn
things I know how to use this all right
he only has one square he's gotta move
him over there and it'll help so I
should take out the queen probably
see Tyler's good at realizing good moves
after he does them but very common in
new players
I mean honestly I feel like that's
common in all players like I do it all
the time I constantly feel like I should
have done a different move the moment I
did it you know yep yep and as we can
see both players are getting into their
own heads xqc was getting his own head
Tyler is realizing he's making mistakes
and it is hard because once you start
looking down on your game you're more
likely to play worst moves
yeah he needs to keep the confidence up
and still think that he can beat xq7
though
but last game he was a piece up an
excuse he was able to to change it so
this might be the same thing Tyler might
be able to make a comeback anyways
foreign
games from Tyler he should keep the
position closed
yeah well he's doing he seems to be
doing it maybe he's putting his Knight
over there Danny wrench in the chat with
a hundred gifted no his own company but
you know the only person taking profit
here is
this but holy I hope there's some
new viewers in the chat who got a test
on the sub with this we know that Danny
wishes he could be here that she's been
hyping up I'm most looking forward to as
well I can maybe amazing Danny that's
absolutely amazing okay I'm happy he
didn't switch
he brought the Knight up
Chad I'm trolling I don't think Danny is
getting the profit from this channel
right
okay this could have been a genius night
maneuver he just has to find like oh
here where do I move then C4 is such a
nice Square attack step on
yeah you can't go night before he's
gonna get trapped there yep he needs to
find it boom only
so what if he goes down right
so I shouldn't it oh no I'm scared he's
gonna go Knight B7 and he's gonna lose
the Knight then
no
that's an immediate night loss then but
he might see it
thinking out loud or here
that's the move that's the GM movement
he does it he baited all of you debated
this is beautiful nice he's attacking
the pawn on E5 now as you see it has to
say that attack has to defend the pawn
and if not then the center is going to
fall apart
but this is nice keeping the game and
the match competitive
for sure and you know I'm seeing some
people saying that we're very one-sided
but the thing here is that xqc won the
first game so we want to see a tie break
that would be epic you know and I think
that people forget that we are chess
players for a living we like to see good
chests whatever side we're watching
we're gonna root for them to find the
best move
exactly we're rooting for the chess
that's it
it's right here xcc has defended upon
great he's trying to infiltrate the
light squares activating his Queen is a
great Strat it would connect his Rooks
he can bring the Rook to the e-file
no one plays chess here
hey don't spill the beans okay
no one's supposed to know
Kevin Knight is hanging out excuses
gotta move the night somewhere but will
you find a good spot I think going back
to E6 is a good one just retreating it
very safe these things would be nice you
could do something similar to Tyler
where he brings his Knight onto that
kind of almost an outpost square and
then by the pawn
yeah there's a few different ones how
many people in chat is this your first
time watching a game of chess
probably not as many as the first POG
Champs but I'm serious
yeah I want to see is this your first
time
no I can't be everyone you guys are
trolling that's the thing I hate asking
chat questions because no one answers
you guys are trolling there's no way
it's everyone's first time watching
chess have you not been seeing the other
POG Champs games well this is the most
awaited one so you know I could see it
all right he played the best night moves
so far both sides playing a great game
chess tournament
upper brackets this is very high level
chass honestly like these night
Maneuvers wow I wish I could maneuver my
night this way
yep now Tyler just needs to activate his
lights card Bishop which is what he said
he struggles he doesn't know how to
develop it he is down in exchange which
means he needs to use
yep absolutely I want to see Tyler
somehow attacking but it's hard to see
how he can create an attack over here
Bishop Rook king queen I like that move
back yes he's finding a way to activate
the bishop a great plan
actually very beautiful and preventing
the knight from coming into that fairy
square that I was talking about
especially needs to activate the rest of
his pieces as well I guess bring the
queen and bring the Rooks that's right
yep he can't leave everything there he
can't just push the pawns he needs to
get the other pieces out
everything else is irrelevance
got it
the actual didn't live my life as a
Victor
of the Paul Champs
X versus Tonka T big Tonka t
all right here we have the live position
um C5 was the last move played by xqc
and now we're looking at moves like
Bishop H3 I mean this bishop getting
activated would be pretty great for
tyler1 woman I mean that's must have
been the reasoning for G3
it must uh
we were wrong Andrea all right you know
still good
B5
I really like it for xqc I think it's
playing very actively let's check out
Tyler one and see what he's he's
thinking right now
It's gotta be very careful
one right here nope he's clearly not
watching the commentary because I've
said many times Knight on the rim is dim
does it move his Pawn no it's so easy to
remember it's like a nursery rhyme it's
free wait isn't it the night on the rim
is grim white dim I either works Grim in
slim it's easy to remember was my point
okay
well he watches all of xqc's games so he
could watch a little bit of our
commentary too
now there's a lot of Pawns hanging the
pawn on B5 the pawn on D3 there's so
many pawns like here
maybe I'll go here so no because
anywhere one of these I move I should
just move it here
he's not sensing the danger attack
there is one big pawn and you cannot
really trade Queens here I feel like the
end game is going to be tough
Chad asked yeah who is winning I go here
oh Tyler's down in exchange so from a
material point of view he is down some
some points
and he's also the one more under attack
but at this level it's hard to say that
that's considered winning
exactly that's a great answer Andrea
that's a great answer so
um this is a great move he is defending
everything
okay here we have the light position
Bishop F1 defending the post now he has
his own threat
he is defending everything but if we
think about what he does
Jesus Christ
he developed his Bishop just have to
bring it back so he's way behind in
development Rolex needs to do is
activate his Rooks and queen and or open
this this is also a good plan so
if he takes this Knight C5 Andrea 95.
it's gonna be very hard
but does like see it let's tune in
okay we knew that would happen right
this is a critical position
very critical he it's the bathroom
Knight C5 threatening the bishop
Tyler needs to bring up the king then go
go go all right delay save let's go what
is X thinking about
he can win a piece
wait hang on Anna but right there Queen
takes odd still winning but it's it's so
much calculation there's no shot he sees
it no offense it is it is actually I
didn't what am I doing I didn't see it
myself
yeah see it wasn't a disc that's the
best all right
do you know what I feel like right now I
feel like I'm in like the medieval times
and I'm having dinner in the garden
Hall
elujah he's having a good time you know
in the garden
I'm gonna try I think the garden is a
symbol Andrea has ever been to a garden
[Music]
this music is so sad
yeah he's playing pretty good maybe yes
he is cheating it no no tonight
look there's always some sort of copium
tyler1 blaming his Mouse slips xqc this
is so nice I like this song Somebody
reps let's do a mic check let's do my
chicken
one
maybe maybe he's meeting out and and
Michaela's singing
night
B6 KH plus three he just doesn't know
how to move the pieces in those versions
because it isn't studied the annotations
[Music]
do you think if we scream Knight B6 and
Tyler was listening that he would know
exactly what 96 is dude I don't think
they even know the names of the squares
maybe they do though but I was gonna say
it's probably very tilting because Tyler
is flexing that 200 points he's been
talking a lot of wait a lower rated
players putting up a fight it gets in
your head and I'm one to talk who
literally lost time odd games to xqc
myself so I get it
yeah no it's easy to to think that
there's something more uh going on here
but
wait I what do you think the chances are
pretend when you're making a comeback
here Andrea
it is still difficult because he's
literally still losing he's still down
material Eve but he's defending so well
it's been scary I'm seeing some ideas
here Andrea I'm seeing some ideas Bishop
takes B5 at some point do you think that
could be a move that Tyler could do
because the rook and the Queen on the
same file I didn't see the lady depends
on stack okay wait it's working because
the queen can't take the pawn because
the knights is he gonna notice
will he do it let's stop something oh
come on Tyler oh my God X sees it does
Tyler see it
bro
no not with that piece the other one the
other one Queen same phone
over here you'll get there process
elimination if I move this Knight back
what if I move this Knight back he is
not cheating confirmed
no this piece up one this piece up too
then we're just playing for pawns I just
hope he doesn't move a piece back you
know he needs activity
this would oh oh
well X has seen it so now he'll defend
but the threat is just gone
he had to sense that open file it could
still happen but X knows any better you
should move his Queen off the file now
before it's too late
oh my God oh my God if he moves the
knights there could be a boat as Gambit
there'd be Bishop check but okay he's
not okay don't move the Knight because
Bishop discovery
then he sucks but he's only getting a
bishop and a rook for a queen
take take
then
yeah I mean queen takes Rook would be a
you know catastrophic for Tyler one
siren I'm sorry do you hear him found a
way to lose the game okay okay
that's supposed to be in a good
neighborhood
it's good I didn't even hear it I was so
zoned in just completely zoned out
all right I'm worried I'm worried about
that nightmare but there's like so
little chance that that check but also I
I mean Knight C5 it looks like he's
gonna do it but Bishop C4 chuck would be
an epic move
Sally even though he would win a queen
from that Tyler's still down two what
three moves
not very efficient is it nope
it would be a big comeback yeah
there's something I'm not thinking about
I have four minutes there's something
I'm not seeing here
push you're right
okay no
push
Tyler once again low on the clock it's
gonna be dangerous
the music is so fitting
I don't know the question is Tyler
thinking ahead and seeing how much
danger there is on this file
yeah I'm wondering that too does he know
oh
this was a really nice move
this was a great move on xpc's part
yeah I'm very very impressed putting
Tyler Under Pressure Tyler's under
almost under a minute and he's under a
great attack Han is defended but he
needs to get his King off that file and
oh he's getting it off the phone but
he's putting the other direction he
needed to go the other way
oh this is so scary now
so far I got him
so far he's still defended but now that
knife move is possible because there's
that Bishop ain't moving now I got him
he has walked into this trap both the
strats here work
okay
this this works you waited for the right
time and you did it spicy
95 Tyler can bring up the night to the
center though that's a spice on a second
that is extra spice
oh that's a good move
he defends good defensive move yes X
wait oh
is there now Knight C5 yep Knight C5 is
working which X spotted it earlier but
it's easy to forget things that you see
but he's playing very well under time
pressure
it's playing quick defensive moves
oh he's going back
now tell her how the chance to move to
the other side oh and now it's okay he
went King yeah
walk the king smack this piece
brought the king to another place just
get it out of here
yep and he gave it to X but oh
Knight D5 trying to Vlog it's not oh
he's gonna blender he's gonna blender
he needs to block the file with the
knife
that's the only way is he gonna see it
with 30 seconds this is 33 pieces right
here this these guys are gone I
might try and protect
this somehow
wait
yeah I can't take that he's looking oh
is gonna be his greatest enemy and
that's yeah now X takes that Bishop its
game
but this is so common time pressure's so
difficult oh all right delay spoiled it
a little bit but it was gonna happen it
was inevitable
oh and The Rook falls down as well now
now it's oh yeah
is gonna get taken down Chad
I think
take
but what a beautifully executed attack
on xqc's part
it's been really beautiful I mean we
still have obviously the still made
ideas
but hey I think excuses got it he knows
about stalemate
take oh
please
yeah I mean Tyler Rose sex is level but
X continued raising the bar kept the
pressure kept the attack both sides
pretty much
yeah and now there's the queen as well
the next meal we're gonna see a queen
check
check playing very confident xqc
chat said first League the conclusion
was obvious
now at the moment to not still mate
check
mate
wow wow that was good that was wrong I
don't I don't want to do these
interviews Anna I'm scared but don't
forget
both sides are going to the championship
this isn't the last you can be seeing of
Tyler you may have lost this match the
most anticipated match but they're still
both Champions and they're still going
into the same bracket
yeah I mean we're gonna check out the
standings but 2-0 uh from xqc that was
honestly I mean the games were closer
than I thought it was going to be like
Tyler really played really well
especially that first game was
absolutely amazing I really thought
Tyler had it there but xqc at the end
was able to win both games so it was a
very strong performance for xqc but we
will see more of them in uh the
championship bracket so here we have the
final standings of Group C xqc with nine
points wow I I haven't even like seen
someone with this many points on draft
Yeah I think xqc got the most wins out
of anyone else in their group
yeah cause he just beat everyone without
even going to tiebreakers so then again
he was a big big favorite in his group
so that's also a reason why and and
Tyler definitely outperformed with how
much experience he has so I'm very much
looking forward to more Tyler games and
to these interviews
me too we are going to be seeing some
interviews both with xqc and tyler1 I'm
terrified but I'm super excited we're
going on we're going on a break and then
after that we'll be seeing the interview
so don't go anywhere we'll see you very
soon
[Music]
Rook takes Knight and now Queen f2q2
just game over like yeah and oh what
he's clean up too oh no oh no oh no
[Music]
Queen F2
oh no oh we missed it and now he's made
it because me Ludwig is a force Maiden
two I know he's made it what a throw
King E8 and then Queen C8 and there's
actually a staircase Checkmate oh man
logic through maybe Seven's mate Rook D6
57 Queen D7 they're three mates here for
white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw let's go
today we're gonna go down into the New
York City subway set up a table on the
subway platform and see if we can get
some strangers waiting for their trains
to play chess with us
[Music]
all right I'm gonna see if I can get
anybody
[Music]
sounds like he knows what he's doing a
little bit
don't worry I'm not that good yeah
you're just out here playing chess not
that good got the chess.com app
give or play on your phone oh yeah he
said he barely played I'm a teacher what
do you teach chess
self-defense how do you stay sane
take medication
what's like lesson 101 of self-defense
run what are you listening to right now
train
Sean Paul Ed Sheeran what is the meaning
of life it's funny because like what I'm
doing I feel like doesn't align with my
philosophy on what the meaning of life
is but it's like obviously spend as much
time with family as possible the best
person you can be
get closer to God not to be evil to each
other
[Applause]
I'll see you in a self-defense class
enjoy Harry Styles
[Music]
whatever
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
two one here we go
foreign
[Music]
2-0 we got them here was this the most
important match of pogchamp so far
sorry was no questions for me
and I don't I don't do what the question
was but let me say my piece xqc was 35
minutes late after being I should have
been getting at least 15 minutes of
extra time to play I would have smoked
them the first round it was panicking
he's 700 rating above me and I had him
shook move for move and wasn't even
close sure second game wasn't wasn't
competitive that was my bad I still did
some trolling his garbage at chess it
needs to uninstall forever
he made me reschedule the last last week
and then he's 30 minutes now late now
ex could see your trash
holy is it like a time bank I had a
talking pillow now and I can talk now
right
yeah I was gonna say I said it earlier
when I was talking I was talking to
broadcast I said it he's he was cheating
it I get it I won I Michaela's on the
room and he's she's getting him the
moves I could tell I I could
tell the way he's moving Michaela was
giving him the moves it's obvious it's
yeah
he was playing web of his rating he was
playing an average of like 900 1.1 K
average as of 200. actually cheating it
is absolutely right I have played above
my level because the prices on Prime and
time again I perform I play up to my
opponent even at games I'm not even the
best at and unfortunately you played
down your opponent he's gonna pip
squeaking squatty in real life xqc
you're lucky this is all you have is is
this little video game career I play
this for fun while I'm working actual
labor jobs in real life and I still
invested you almost
labor job Liberty you play League of
Legends what is it talking about
I work on pool labor
starters and repair pools actually
okay
I'll let you talk oh well I I I I have a
landscaping job and an office job and I
stream it and I play chess I'd imagine
probably yeah an hour late to that too
and in the real world xqc that's not
acceptable and hopefully in the
chess.com world that's not acceptable
for the quarters either but you show up
an hour late for that maybe he'll face
some punishment
this small person big-headed muscle head
is still molding it because I cheated
against him in twitch Rivals and I got
banned I got banned for a week for it
and I couldn't stream it and he wanted
to take revenge it he called Michaela to
cheat against me to get his revenge and
even would make it 2V1 I beat them two V
one two brains can you get the mine any
comment teller
yeah I have I have about 15 comments
Number One X you see to have to bring in
IRL stuff about that because look at you
you're pale you look like a ghost bro
that can't be healthy you weigh 75
pounds again remember me snapping the
pin I could snap you bro first of all
you don't want to bring iron all of this
because I beat you and everything in
that secondly stop accusing me of
cheating it's just a compliment because
I wasn't okay and then thirdly about the
cheating comment with you cheating yes
hello he's admitted cheating in a
previous tournament hello
yes you beat me this time well by the
way you will not go to the semis you are
terrible by the way no no character
aside you are actually terrible Israel
I will I did put terrible okay but when
your opponent is way way way it's more
than enough
your thoughts bro you strong against
squeaks and that dude sucks
against him
oh okay well squeaks is really really
really really really bad you're not
wrong
um I mean the guy was he was he was
wearing a wig that's enough about him it
was wearing a wig that's true
that is insane
secure from the start that's true that's
true
let me let me get this way we could both
play a year of Chess you wouldn't beat
me I we yeah I lifted if I lifted for a
year I would beat your PB I said it
excuse me
it sounds bro I squat 600 pounds put the
arms away you have nothing to show
are we gonna allow him to embarrass
production like this dude you're not
serious
yes
for sure have you not I heard that you
were getting GM pointers by that hikiru
guy for that guy's name is and he was
Bond reviewing me and then leaking it to
you probably true actually and even
playing this is your like second POG
Champs right or your third I don't know
how many of these have there been I
don't keep track this is my first one
actually I was watching
um she gave up on you entirely
he he actually retired yeah I Hikaru he
watched it again but he actually retired
he hasn't seen in a long time
while playing he was like oh I'll never
match this guy and he retired I made him
quit chess congrats I'm a freak
well you know it's lovely to see you
guys really passionate about the game
and Pog Champs and you know Tyler
there's plenty of Grandmasters who could
coach this was a really lovely
professional interview which um
for a second give me your honest opinion
I played impressive chess compared to
before you did
um
by the way
no I I yep we were gonna say at the end
of the day no matter what's going on
with who can Flex harder who has bigger
muscles let's not forget that the people
United for chess today and Tyler you
played a great game the truth is you're
200 rated and xqc
you played much above your level and
today you Rose to the ranks and we are
very excited because both of you guys
are gonna be making it to the
championship bracket which means you may
battle again and now there's gonna be
even more more insane chess competition
um so we'll really we really love how
much you guys love chess and you know
how competitive you are and Tyler it was
nice to see you do some studying it was
good to see the cow today we're happy to
help with chess lessons Hikaru has
retired so um you know you'll have to
settle first Grand Master
big Tonka 200 I'll see you on the next
game brother
he's not 200.
it's the it was a glitch in the system
you'll get you'll get the rating tighter
um who are you guys most excited to play
in the championship bracket
both of you yeah
no
we both go talk to the bracket learn how
they work yeah you guys you're yeah you
both made it this game was just for
pride and stuff you're in the same
okay I don't think Genie has ever seen a
chessboard before and squeaks was busy
playing Connect Four in the middle of
the game how is it fair that he gets a
free passes to the bracket
he's 200 and he played very well so I
think it's very well dessert
um I don't know anybody on this list
unfortunately so I don't know well looks
like you guys are each other's greatest
enemies you don't know sapnap he plays
Minecraft blood is called the German xqc
and Frank was awesome but he's not
really well known outside of the chess
Community
I played I know Sat Nav I played league
with them once
you guys are kind of you know it's an
identity crisis if you guys play each
other
you can be a golden egg okay but I'm the
Golden Goose okay there's multiple
version of xc's I get from all other
languages it doesn't matter I am better
how many copies of Taiwan is there none
nobody because
erupt is pretty close I'm just kidding
outside okay we're we're related by
blood only relax
ha
okay final question do you think that
you will face each other in the live
finals in LA
if he makes it to the finals so so uh
we'll let you guys be in the same room
to be honest I'm flying from Sweden
challenge to see that I've promised that
I will do it
I'm not scared I'm not scared to one
okay I I would do chess boxing against
them even though even though muscles
and I'm not even talking about the
boxing portion you'd lose it five
seconds on the chess portion
my sister weighs more than you actually
see and she's nine
okay but that doesn't change it's like
you have a T-Rex Builder
T-Rex Andy so how does it work guys guys
he's flexing for the camera we all know
this it's fine do we have to win the
whole thing on each side of uh uh how
many people go to La exactly only the
two finalists you guys would both have
to be top in your group to meet yeah and
the consolation finalists so four people
in total
I hope he makes it I actually hope he
makes it anyway uh you know I didn't
really want to go back to L.A because I
just left L.A I escaped L.A and I have
to go back now for your tournament
it is what it is
I'm just kidding I I'll win the whole
tournament embarrass you online okay
Lanchester in the same as online chess
if you thought you had it hard I will
you up in real life
xqc now you're talking crazy now
watch it watch yourself watch it I'll
see Atlanta
well this is I think the match-up that
we all need to see to settle this once
and for all Tyler if you want to get
coach to Prodigy they will do it same
for ux but we know you would like to do
your own type of studying but Tyler I
want to see you guys go face to face I
think this is the chat match that chat
wants to see most yeah I mean I'm
playing the cow Tyler keep on playing
the counter yeah
I I messed it up but you were shook
a week in advance people are still
looking for it
I was eating chicken dude right there
and I thought about you and the game of
chess and I fell asleep it doesn't count
I took a small impromptu nap okay I was
dreaming about you
can't wait to see you Tyler
okay yeah as you see why you keep saying
that okay can we move on now he's being
weird
yep all right ladies and gentlemen thank
you guys for joining us this was a
really lovely interview we're looking
forward to more chess and
um let's let's go to the standings
yeah thank you so much let's check out
it was a pleasure guys thanks so much
thank you yes yes
okay here we have
no it's okay you're good you're good all
right bye Tyler bye-bye okay so here we
have the standings
um sorry we were saying bye to excuse me
and Tyler um so here we have the
standings these are the final standings
in the groups we got group a group b
Group C and D everything is decided but
you're gonna keep on seeing these
players play okay this was not the last
time you're seeing them play we are
going now for the bracket stage of POG
Champs where we're gonna be having
eliminations and it's gonna be so much
fun I am so excited to watch this Andrea
immediate eliminations from now on
starting tomorrow yep Chad you're gonna
have to be rooting hard for your
favorite streamer everyone's gonna be
grinding studying
um I mean I can't just I can't help but
want both Tyler and xqc to win after
today even though I have to say I do
feel like a Survivor I don't know what
we just witnessed and I don't know
not to react I'm sitting there I didn't
know what to say I was hoping you'd say
something but I didn't even know what we
could say it was a really good interview
on our part um but I would love to see
like jokes aside I want to see Tyler
take some lessons he did some studying
and it drastically helped him I want to
see them meet up IRL and play in LA
despite what xqc might say that would be
so hype maybe chest boxing one day I
mean I can't say I feel like that would
be fair I feel like I could chest box
sex you see myself however maybe kiss
boxing or something else they could try
for Tyler and them
yep yep
I agree I mean Chaz boxing would be
pretty amazing to be honest I do want to
see them do that but um let's go ahead
and check out the field in the
championship bracket because we got both
excuse the entire one we already know
that but we got lots and more people we
got Sea Dog vile we got Frank we got
ghastly sapnap xqc tyler1 I did a thing
and papa plot Andre I'm asking you right
here and right now who's the winner of
Pop Champs five oh God after I went I
just witnessed Santa I can't make a
single prediction Tyler is willing to
die for this game and you know what I
love it I was a little shy on the mic
but that's the energy that we need these
days people are acting like there's not
enough on the line for chess the World
Chess Championship is dying the losing
viewership this is what we need we need
something serious and I'm all here for
it and you know even though they didn't
know all the competitors in the graphic
in the bracket there is a huge group we
have Sea Dog I did a thing some of the
greatest YouTubers in the world
obviously we have Frank the face of noob
chess and not saying that as a disc he
it's grown and made 700 chests a
universal type of content that everyone
loves there's a lot of great
personalities so we're very much looking
forward to it we definitely are and
Andrea I have some news to share and
well all of you people I got some big
news to share let's hear it I think we
got the pairings
okay all right oh my God we weren't
supposed to get him today and this is
for tomorrow
four well I don't know I don't know
who's playing no or the brown just for
the bracket let's see it okay
okay so in the
in the championship we got sea Dogma in
sapnap we've got
I did a thing and Tyler won
okay very tough for Tyler and if you
lose this he's kicked out and eliminated
right Anna yeah immediately immediately
then it's over then it's his run is over
in podcast I did a thing is a very
strong opponent we saw him destroy cutie
Cinderella yesterday you know we can
give him some lessons but that's that's
a fight that I want to see it be Head to
Head
I believe that the cow will be able to
to do its thing though but yeah it's
gonna be a tough fight ghastly versus
Frank's is here
that's my product again
yeah I'm very excited about that one and
then oh
oh you will not believe it
xqc versus
okay nice it's it's like Spiderman the
two xqcs meet in the whatever Universe
of Chess this is gonna be awesome I
don't know if they've ever played
against each other definitely not in a
game of chess but it's gonna be hard to
tell who's who that's gonna be a pretty
hype pretty hype match I've been saying
let the better juicer win loser has to
change their hair
I think so too I mean I think we should
come up with the color
so we also got the consolation though we
can't forget about the constellation
bracket that's a very important bracket
too and in that one we're gonna be
getting Jarvis versus daily dose of
Internet that one's gonna be exciting
Jarvis has been you know been playing
really well with daily dose as well yeah
probably our two most sane and con
players after what we've seen today so
you can expect some high quality chests
and thank you to Cinderella versus Ginny
uh they're gonna be facing each other
and then we have virtual versus psychuno
did get a win that's amazing I yeah
baikuno told me his one goal was to get
one win this tournament I think same for
Ginny
um that's gonna be a very tough match as
we know virtual has been studying and
training
um so I think I think it's gonna be
clear some of the favorites in this
category however I would love to see I
would love to see some good chess and
maybe some lessons from everyone in this
group
I agree I think it's gonna be really
exciting and then in the final final one
in the constellation bracket we got
squeaks versus firstly I'm very excited
to see that match actually I think it
might be close
yeah two of the most wholesome
Personalities in here squeaks has been
catching Strays all day when he's so
wholesome it's so so nice to play with
and watch so I think that's perfect
energy for fusely
I think it's gonna be really fun to see
that I'm very excited well with this
Andrea I think that um I I need to get
some I need to get some rest after the
interview we had guys Park Champs 5 is
over for today it's been so fun and so
exciting don't forget to check out the
chess.com socials as well to see you
know all the brackets again if you've
missed them thank you so much everybody
for watching the show today it's been so
much fun and thank you Andrea for for
being here as well and saving me I'm
about to go live chat my day continues
chess is gonna rainbow test live Tina's
joining the woman I chest box and we
will see you very soon
thanks for watching
[Music]
we get two cows in a row
created a monster it's only three pieces
right here these guys are gone
wow that was good that was wrong I don't
want to do these interviews Anna I'm
scared
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wow
foreign
[Music]
thank you
one here we go
[Music]
three two one here we go
thank you
foreign
[Music]